las calles le viven el pulso al
presidente interino manuel merino
cientos de manifestantes se volcaron a
las calles de la capital por tercer día
consecutivo para protestar contra la
destitución del ex mandatario martín
vizcarra rechazando la decisión
legislativa que algunos calificaron de
ilegal
estamos en las calles que espontánea y
pacíficamente defendiendo la democracia
peruana de un atropello del congreso que
pretende acabar con ella
previo a las manifestaciones merino ex
presidente del congreso juramento a su
gabinete ministerial liderado por el
primer ministro ántero flores-aráoz
hecho que fue duramente cuestionado por
el exmandatario martín vizcarra
respuesta se la está dando el pueblo al
señor merino y más aún cuando nombra
como presidente del consejo de ministros
al señor flores aráoz es como volver al
pasado a la política tradicional
vizcarra fue destituido por el congreso
el 9 de noviembre tras ser declarado
incapaz moralmente de continuar en el
cargo el legislativo alegó actos de
corrupción que denunciaron cuatro
testigos cuando el ex presidente era
gobernador de moquegua acusaciones que
no ha aceptado ni el presidente ni
formalmente la fiscalía ni los
manifestantes pero el nuevo ministro del
trabajo peruano expresó otra cosa en
france 24 si bien es cierto nosotros
respetamos las manifestaciones populares
también es cierto que no podemos sino
decirme que están equivocados el
gobierno del presidente merino es
absoluto absolutamente legal y
constitucional y por otro lado la
situación del presidente fiscal era
insostenible se habían comprobado que
había mentido en innumerables veces y
las acusaciones de haber recibido su
amor
hoy más por obras públicas jazz eso ya
convertía su mandato en insostenible la
crisis política que merino prometió
acabar llega en medio de la crisis
económica y sanitaria auspiciada por la
pandemia y promete no irse pronto